this is the pain you this is this move
out hundred a lot Salaam alaikum peace
be with you I'm it of your host you're
watching the DS show and this week we're
going to be talking about rights rights
in islam human rights civil rights man's
rise what kind of Rights do I get when I
embrace Islam when I testify okay that
you know what there's one God and I want
to worship this got alone I give him all
the rights first then what do I get in
return I'm gonna be talking about these
kind of rights here on the Dean show
with the author of the lies about
Muhammad in mine mr. Furze aid right
back this is the days of Athene jus this
is the things
this is the thank you assalamo alaikum
Salam our hotel over cuts please be with
you you too likewise brother now you're
the author of the lies about Muhammad
yes you got your own section at the Dean
show calm how you feeling from the left
feeling great yeah thank you for being
with us this is like a la fam I'm really
excited talking to you about Islam Islam
is something beautiful is something that
over 1.5 million people around you know
billion I'm sorry billion people
implement live by and it's something
that we really are trying to share with
the people because we care about the
people yes so when somebody now
acknowledges what's in their very nature
that they want to worship the One God
alone without any Co equals co-partners
just god-given got all his rights they
want to know now what kind of rises
Islam give me this Islam like subjugate
me does it put me down and lift me up
talk about some of the human rights in
islam actually the number one
fundamental right and he just touched
upon it is the right of Liberty the fact
that I worship the one mighty God and I
don't worship anyone else and there's no
middle man between me and my Creator I
yield only to my Creator there lies the
true liberty of man that's number one
that's number one liberty of matter
second thing look at the Declaration the
first declaration of human rights in the
history of mankind who said it it was
problem Hamas is Ellen it wasn't like
some people claim that it was the French
Revolution equality liberty and
brotherhood or the United Nations
Declaration of Human Rights it was
problem homicide asylum in the last
pilgrimage all men are equal no white
better than a black or black better than
a white except by fearing God and guess
what who can measure fearing god only
god can see what's in your heart no man
can brings us to another right no one
can question your ideology or you
believe you believe in whomever you want
and based on that Allah subhana Allah
will judge you no man can come to one
person say you are a hypocrite or you
are an infidel or your quality of
amanda's have for fuller it's only God
so no one can question your faith or
your personal information more than that
everyone is equal
in the eyes of the law you are not
Muslim who lives in a Muslim country you
have exactly the same rights and I want
to give an example a true historical
event and by that you show the quality
of the Islamic law and civil rights by
the practicality of it we all know the
example of our Constitution of the
founding father saying that all men are
created equal but practically it was all
white men created equal at the time
later on it was not just white people or
land owning why people are created equal
this is in the Constitution Constitution
but practically that what it was black
men were not considered a part of that
Constitution at the time they were like
three fifths yes nowadays practically
it's all corporations are created equal
and we just filling material just about
the practicality of it the most powerful
man in the world at the time mod I leben
avatar he lost his shield in one of the
battles and then all of a sudden in a
market seen his shield with a Jewish man
most powerful man in the world a
minority in all Muslim country and
Jewish of all people and then he says
this is my shield the Jewish man said
this no it's mine imagine the rights
that the Jewish man had to the level
that he would stand up to Obama of his
time of George Bush of his time and
saying no knowing that it's nice shield
he knows that it's a leading epithalamus
shield and he knows that I leave never
type knows it is his own shield what
happens I didn't Abby totally brings
himself as the most powerful man in the
world to stand before an Islamic judge
as mandated by Islamic law you're the
ruler you're the servant we all equal
before the law and the judge by the way
was an African man judge right but the
other one judge said let me listen I
leave data type said I'm telling you
it's my shield I can bring you a hoss
animal for saying the grandchildren of
from homicide Salem to testify that this
is my shield and then he has a Jewish
man once he proved he said what more
proof that you need that I have position
is my shield I'm carrying it what did
the judge rule he said I rule for the
shield to be for the Jewish man because
in Islamic law you kids your wife and
you are considered one entity so their
testimony is exactly like yours so it's
your word against him but he has
position according to Islamic law then
the possession is
what you ruled by and he ruled the
shield to the Jewish man the Jewish man
looked at this and said I want to be
nothing but a Muslim and declared his
shot on the spot indeed the shield back
of course I think it was amazing story
this is amazing so the most powerful man
he could have just taken it away chopped
his head off he didn't do none of that
and it was his shield and it was this
year and you know what the most
important thing is that i leave vitaly
be yielded to the ruling when the judge
said that he said I walk away an Islamic
court and I stood and I had my chance
and the law of a loss of chanukah i said
i should not have position of the shield
I yield so this is totally opposite to
what some people would try to claim that
Islam is just about if you don't get
your way to chop your head off we know
about chopping people's matter of fact
in my book the lies about Mohammed I
brought the testimony for a very good
objective research by the Oracle
Institute about the major religions the
world including Hinduism and Sikhism and
all that kind of stuff and in it in
plain English they say that if it wasn't
for Islam Judaism would have not existed
today if you look at the abhorrence
oppression and injustice and persecution
to the Jews on the hands of some
Christians which it's totally against
the teachings of Jesus peace be upon him
if it wasn't Muslim countries a Muslim
rule that allowed Jews to exist and
worship God freely like what happened in
Dallas then they would have not existed
in countries like England a lot of
people be surprised that Jews were
banned even to exist in England for 350
years at the same time in the end Alice
in Spain and Porter golf today where
Islamic law was applied they just did
not live or worship freely they thrived
with Christians and Muslims in the same
country for eight centuries that's
Islamic law but people amid that history
and try to tell you what Muslims are
anti this and anti that as if history is
wiped of the face of the earth and only
the lies would last wow this is amazing
amazing facts and you're learning and
you'll get to learn more sit tight we'll
be right back on a Dean show i dont la
but how
Allah Allah Allah high in na na na egg
bomb I love egg bone soup at Allah
alhamdulillah Allah Allah high in na na
na like bomb I love i bum I don't lie
when hamdulillah I'm la illaha illallah
w'allahu egg bomb I love i bum a soup i
dont la when hamdulillah I'm la illaha
in na na na egg bum I love i bum I don't
lie when hamdulillah I'm gonna heal i ha
e na na na egg bomb I love egg bone soup
at online hamdulillah I'm gonna a la
enana want another egg bomb I love egg
bomb this is the thing is the theme
this is the video this is the danger why
is our news media foaming at the mouth
when it comes to stories about Islamic
terrorists but not white guy terrorists
is that because Muslims are a bigger
threat in fact between 1980 and 2005
ninety-four percent of all the attempted
or successful terrorist attacks on US
soil were not carried out by Islamic
radicals but instead by non-muslims
mostly white guys so then why the
obsession it's killing of innocent human
beings human life is precious you will
not feel a woman do not kill a child do
not you know going to different
religious leaders Buddhism in Division
forms of Christianity I even ran into
people from the Nation of Islam feeling
brave man you will not feel an animal
you will not cut a tree down do not
believe the water do not burn their
homes back here on the Dean show we're
talking about rights and you mentioned a
story about a Jewish man and the rights
that Islam gave to this individual and
then you went on to talk about just jus
days of surviving because Muslims what
they do they took them in and protected
them from others who were trying to use
the non-muslim as long as he pays his do
tax as a Muslim pases do tax he has the
rights and obligations and he is equal
in the eyes of the law of you steal from
a Jew you get punished exactly the same
way as you have stole from a Muslim and
you hurt a Jew it is the same way as
you've done it all Muslim the matter of
fact they have a little bit more
protection because prophet muhammad's
slm said in a correct hadith whoever
would hurt easy me or my hit someone who
give us a pledge I would hear by Islamic
law even though I'm non-muslim and I'll
give you peace and he give me peace and
we gave that pledge and you go above and
beyond and transgress and hurt him then
prob mom says I'm said you're not going
to smell the
you'll agree season and the the perfume
of gender can be felt like 70 years
apart now tell us that we know slavery
slavery was something that was normal it
was normal during the time of Jesus and
Moses now the African Americans they
just got many of their rights today yes
did islam encourage the freeing of the
slaves way back even before this it's a
panel is a big devil NCAP whatever i
call with that were they around then no
they weren't and actually you brought a
very good point and you can only see the
genius of the islamic solution to the
city every problem in light of the Civil
War right here in America Abraham
Lincoln and rightly so he said there's
no such thing as a man owning another
man a polished slavery what happened
people said you know what according to
the existing system I paid for that
slave I own that slave my current crop
is totally dependent on these slave
workers now we're destroying my business
you taking my property away I'm going to
go to war and that's what happened
that's how the Civil War started look at
the solution for Islam yes you own yes
you paid and I want to come to your
right but it divided the sources of
slavery abolished Reba you know
interest-bearing and you know bad loans
that people got enslaved by abolish
slavery promise I said I'm said a lot so
kind of odd be an opponent of you and
judgment day if you enslave some man and
sell him for money but the opponent of
God himself so band so the sources and
the river that slavery you know I
survived from the source is dried and
then gave tremendous reward for whoever
with free a slave so the Companions
spend their fortunes buying slaves and
frame by and sleeves and Freeman the
matter of fact gave also the right to
slaves you can go away from your owner
and work and bring money and buy your
own freedom and call it maquettes about
overtime without calling a civil war
like what happened here hundreds of
thousand people died and trillions of
dollars were wasted slavery was
abolished in Islam and you look at the
decency and we're talking now about the
human rights of Islam look at the
comparison from isela one of the great
companions be led
the one who recites the SN and the
coding for the prayers Blair was African
look at the hall model hot tub
describing abu bakr siddiq omer hot tub
is the second halifa after the ruler
after promise I seldom and Abu Bakr is
the first Khalifa he was talking about
Abu Bakr Umar talking about a block he
said say you doona what Atticus ayuda
Abu Bakr is my master and he set free my
other master who's this other master
bellaire the African who abu bakr siddiq
told his owner i would pay his weight in
gold and free look at the respect for
the belief in people and the quality of
people aside from the color of their
skin or what they are the companies are
from Hamas a semi got so hyped the Roman
you got salman the persian you got
balerdi african you got abu bakr umar
the arabs and from all tribes and
everyone was the same everyone treated
equal everyone given rights even the
neighbor and it's lab just for being
somebody's neighbor promised slm said
you lose the status of your Islam if you
sleep on a full stomach and your
neighbor is hungry he gave rise to the
neighbor just someone who's living next
to me that whoever is you know a
believer Allah subhana Allah should be
generous to his neighbor as if you are
responsible for your neighbor look at
the mandate for peace between you and
everyone around you and the rights that
are lost I gave everyone an equal you
know treatment and equal peace and
righteousness and courtesy to everyone
around you that is Islam these are human
rights real human right yes amazing
amazing we'll be right back with more
here in the D show
ooh
ooh
who show us the way to all the squares
this is the Dean did a visa this is the
D did hubby
who
it's a way of life or two was bad the
messenger best of me show us the way to
Alice grace this is the Dean Dean of a
slam this is the Dean Dean of is
back here on the Dean show we're talking
rights human rights we talked about the
slaves and how Islam encouraged the
freeing of the slaves without actually
even taking the rights away from those
people or persons who might have before
Islam had slaves yes yeah you talked
about that and what about now the
minority let's say the minority
Christians are non-muslims and a Muslim
land what kind of Rights do they have we
spoke about the Jewish minority let's
talk about Christians we're now here
minorities in a Christian land
predominant Greenland how was the
Christians treated in Muslim land this
is unheard of in the history of mankind
when Islam was at its Venus of power
probably three years before the passing
of promise I Salem the majority
Christians in the epic Peninsula we're
in a area called nazron a town called
nazron promise I sent and received him
all in the medina and the capital of the
Muslim state had him perform their
prayers and the rich was inside the
Muslim mosque his own mask the mask of
the Prophet of Islam and the one they
came out told them the law that we just
recited that you lacombe malena walaikum
Molina you have our rights and
obligations and you have our rights and
obligations no matter of fact in the
middle of 7th century even though there
were not there were some Christians that
would believe like unitarians that Jesus
is a prophet of God and he is worship
Almighty God no they believed in the
Trinity which is blasphemy according to
our ideology but it's their right to
worship whatever they want you tell him
the message you tell him what Islam is
and hits their choice and that's the
Islamic way and that was the Prophet way
he said if your churches would get old
and start to fall apart we would repair
him for you from the Muslim Treasury
from the taxes that we obligate the
Muslims to pay and it's not even a debt
upon you and that's how they were
treated Jerusalem was firing invaders
left on my through history the only time
that the leaders of Jerusalem said we
would surrender the keys to a ruler or
leader was all marble hot tub the Muslim
because they know that their rights are
protected when the Muslim would rule it
never mind you cannot even compare that
to the Romans or
you know all other invaders that invaded
and they open the city and they stated
that Omar is the one would receive the
keys to Jerusalem all Martin the hot tub
goes there the most powerful man in the
world and get the keys prayer times
comes in when he was meeting them in
their own church he said I need to pray
they said go ahead and pray it's an
honor for us said no I would pray
outside I don't want a Muslim to come
and say I have seen Homer praying here
this is a message it let's take it over
as a message it Wow and he prayed
outside in the middle of the seventh
century yet you find people coming to
tell you you know what you're a Muslim
you wake up you have breakfast and go
try to kill couple questions totally
false absolutely be further from that
now tell us earlier you said in the
beginning of the show that the Judaism
wouldn't have survived unless the
Muslims were as merciful and they
protected the Jews from absolution or
solution all the time look at the
Inquisition's yes what happened Jews
escape to when the you know friend
Isabel came to and Muslims and Jews
cannot live here you're a Jew you
convert or we kill you what did they
escape to the nearest Muslim countries
there were the only places in the world
that they can exist worship freely and
thrive in Muslim countries now someone I
go to some anti-islamic site and they
say hold on hold on this guy's feet neil
eyes look look prob muhammad peace be
upon him he had 700 Jews executed how
would you actually I well as label to go
to objective scholars there were three
tribes in Medina the first one was about
Ben okay haha he was the ruler of Medina
and they were against his religion the
norm at the time he would go you convert
to Islam you you know live under my
control or I'll kill you all and that
was the norm who is this now you know II
don't know any leader at the time what
I've done that what would promise slm
said said live under autonomy let's have
peace between you and me and I got
nothing to do with you he had lived in
peace the first tribe a woman slow
movement want to buy from a gold Mershon
there they tied her dress to a chair and
when she wanted to stand up actually she
was tripping a kit she screamed a Muslim
man came in and fought with them he
killed the shop owner and he was killed
and by that according to any standard of
the time
they breached that peaceful covenant
with the Muslims so you have a peace
treaty but now you disrespected an
honorable woman and exposed [ __ ]
Akeldama slim and men what tried to
protect her yeah at the norm of the time
Prophet Muhammad has the right to go and
kill him all women children everyone
what did promise is also mentioned in
Old Testament is Amit is yes at the
notice and I can quote you actually in
the Old Testament and and it's actually
not true because it speaks about you
have an enemy you go to that village
kill everyone burn it down to the ground
by the Old Testament Oh test I burn it
down and walk away and you know what I
know a lot of chanukah would not allow
indiscriminate killing of innocent
people what would prefer Mahama's I sell
em due to these people he said I could
not trust you anymore take all your
valuable properties and leave and settle
somewhere else except your arms so you
don't come and fight me back and let him
walk free not one man was touch and they
took all the properties with them as if
that wasn't enough been on nadir the
second tribe what happened now Islam is
growing and they don't like that growing
power next to them so they make a fatal
error their leader oh yeah it knocked up
invited promise I sent him to come visit
them so promises on goes to visit them
what did they have prepared for him they
had a man wait for the prophet and asked
him to go wait for our leader under that
house and he'll be right back and they
had a man carrying a huge rock on top of
the house to throw it on the head of
promise I sell em and kill him to
naively make it look like an access ass
ination assassination attempt and kill
the Prophet of Islam in cold blood and
he did nothing wrong to them what
happened is Allah subhana gotta send
archangel gabriel and warning they're
about to kill you they did not know that
they killing the last prophet of God
Allah Allah would not destroy him and
destroy the final message of God
promises on left what would anyone do
nowadays any type of history kill them
all without mercy and you'll be
justified promises and again said you
preach the treaty it is not even
prosecute the Lear or the man who wanted
to stand there or the man who's standing
on top all together walk out with your
most valuable properties whatever their
you want to carry without your arms now
the third tribe did way beyond because
vamos slm has this rule and you can see
that you attack promises and personally
and he can retaliate he would forgive
you but you attacked muslims or islam
that is a right upon him he cannot
forgive very important point what they
did to him personally he would forgive
yes now if you attack the community as a
whole well then is they have a right a
different story now Koresh said that you
know what we want to make the biggest
army in our history and go and Niall
eight Mohammed and Islam forever in what
is known as the Battle of the trench so
they were gone there and laying siege
around the Muslims and the only open
area that they can attack the Muslims
came up salman the persian came up with
the idea let's dig a trench that as wide
as deep that horses cannot cross by that
we protect ourselves ten thousand
fighters from crush they will go there
and annihilate Islam what would the last
and third tribe of the Jews of Medina
would do battle coryza what would they
do automatically with the treatment and
the peaceful treatment and the leniency
the promises and showed him and even the
other Jews that transgressed they
decided that you know what we're going
to complete the siege around Muhammad
and take allies of courage to the end of
Muhammad and the annihilation of
Muhammad and they put seizure running
for over two weeks rough Muhammad SAW
Salem was starving he was 57 years of
age and a man came to him and said you
know I have this piece of chicken I'm
going to take it for myself promises M
said why didn't you split it with your
brothers no you know me a muslim
brothers the men exposed his stomach and
there was a rock tied to stomach so he
can withstand the hunger problem as a
sensual his stomach he had two works he
was 57 years of age and they would have
killed them all but with the you know
the blessing of allah subhana tannin and
fruit trickery and a huge sandstorm that
actually blew the tents of croatia and
put out their fires they could not
locate themselves and keep the siege
they had to go back to [ __ ] now these
people who committed treachery
annihilating muslims to the end and
would be in tension and if they want the
norm of christ and burn Eliza was to
kill almost times now what would anyone
do promises and said I'm not gonna judge
it I would bring the most interacting
and one who deals mostly with business
with the Jews saddlemen wise to be the
judge between the end them he'd even
refused even to judge it sadden me as I
said you can not by any stretch of the
imagination not execute the men that
were set out there to kill us all they
have to be executed as war criminals
committing treachery and that's the same
ruling any court-martial court in the
world at any time of history would have
done and at the time they were that
killed the women and children as well
this is treason treason of the highest
highest level they executed the the men
and spared their women and spread the
children and any objective historian who
looked at this he said of course are you
out of your mind look at the world at
the time they're lucky even that the
battle clinica in the beginning were not
killed all and burn oh no dear come all
and even other people would not even
wait for the last one to commit your
treachery treachery and they would
actually one there and killed everyone
so in itself this is a sign of ultimate
leniency after the betrayal of the other
two tribes that promise has ended was it
was it true that they were charged what
is mandated in the Torah and their
scripture or the Torah mandates killing
them all yeah women and children and
warriors the worries that we're about to
kill all Muslims all the tribes and all
the sevens of all properties would be
seized so that their law there they're
always like the same thing and that's
why I don't know why I said I cannot be
more lenient than execute the people
commit treason and spare the other
children and women that are not to blame
wow this is amazing I wanted to bring
this up because all right there in the
book lies about Muhammad and really
recommend that you get this book because
all hundred fifty-five false allegations
against the last and final messenger
sent to man kind of problem and peace be
upon them their answer this is the first
English book that addresses all these
channels available on Amazon and tsunami
just the lies and deception these
childish things I don't bring people
together they just bring people further
apart we want people to work together
towards goodness they're inciting hatred
between Americans and other Americans
people forget the Muslim Americans guess
what are Americans yes and we were here
before Christopher Columbus yes we've
been here long and the map proves it in
the Mac food thank you very much they
got a body really taken so much and that
was human rights in islam just giving
you a taste just giving you a little bit
of taste of the Justice of Islam not
only towards those who submit their will
to the will of the One God but also to
the not yet Muslims Islam is something
rational logical if you take a
scientific analytical approach you'll
see that this system this complete way
of life is from no other but the creator
of the heavens and earth and this whole
universe and everything in it we invite
you to call the number 1 866 to Islam to
learn more and to even get a copy of the
Quran which is the rebate on word of god
continue to tune in here every week and
until next time peace be unto you
whoo it's a way of life or two was bad
the messenger best of megan show us the
way to allah's grace this is the d did
Alison this is the D D nervous